you probably are not going to be shocked
by what I am going to tell you today or
at least not surprised but this is a
major major scandal and it is not
getting the attention that it deserves a
top climate scientist has quit the USDA
and claims that the Trump administration
is burying climate research data again
not surprising but a major scandal which
may not even rank given everything
that's going on right now his name is
Luis Sisca he's a leading climate change
scientists he has a study published in
science advances at the journal which
says that more carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere causes rice to lose nutrients
okay understand the implications climate
change literally makes food less
nutritious you would think that the USDA
a being agriculture would immediately be
activating around this because 600
million people on the planet depend on
rice to get enough calories syska has
now gone public that the Trump
administration questioned his findings
and tried to minimize media coverage of
this study this is not a unique claim
from Sisca Politico did an investigation
and they found that a whole bunch of
government employees have actually lost
their jobs over climate change
disagreements with the Trump
administration and that the USDA is
regularly doing this they're regularly
burying research that is not favorable
to Donald Trump's view of climate change
which by the way is the topic Trump
knows nothing about but has no shortage
of opinions on the right loves to talk
about who isn't getting to be heard they
talked about the suppression of speech
they blame us on the left for limiting
speech and suppressing speech they
totally misunderstand what the First
Amendment is and what free speech and
censorship even mean and here we have
scientists doing science being silenced
for political reasons even the Trump
administration is in a position here
where they are not just suppressing
speech they're doing even more to hurt
climate research 550
federal workers at the USDA we're told
hey you know what we're gonna move the
office from Washington DC to Kansas City
a place that a lot of people who live in
Washington DC don't want to go with
peace and love and all due respect to
Kansas City uprooting countless families
and of course a lot of the people who
have worked for the USDA for a long time
are quitting and who do you think
they're going to be replaced by people
that the new USDA under Trump wants to
hire there have been lots of horrible
things happening long before Trump
obviously but we're now seeing this sort
of sinister amalgamation of the worst
instincts combined with the worst people
combined with the worst ideas combined
with a complete lack of morality and
extreme greed and this is where they're
going with it they aren't just trying to
suppress science and real research on
the climate they are doing it they are
succeeding at doing it and it's not a
salacious or headline-grabbing as a lot
of the other stuff that too many people
are spending their time on so a lot of
people don't even realize that this is
happening and the effect is irreversible
in many ways and sickening and so I'm
doing my part to try to let you know
that this is going on I understand that
the more salacious headlines will
continue to get more attention corporate
media is unlikely to talk about this but
for the side that claims they are the
victims of the suppression of speech and
facts they are doing a hell of a lot of
that suppression themselves make sure
that you are following the david pakman
show on twitch at twitch.tv slash david
pakman I hope you'll join me Wednesday
evening at 6:30 p.m. Eastern for a live
twitch stream and if you have an Amazon
Prime subscription you can subscribe to
twitch prime for free it costs you
nothing but it counts as a paid
subscription for us all of that at
twitch.tv slash david pakman I hope
you'll check it out